ah welcome back to the machine with
bowels Jesus Christ
when will you stop harassing me I don't
understand you make an all change why
they harass I mean I never done them
anything anything bad but they always
give me [ __ ] I don't understand anyway
we're gonna go through the Zeppelin I'm
not sure what a Zeppelin is but it's not
a pretty cold shot we're gonna go there
first stairs I shouldn't eat so much
before it okay Betty I hear you're back
do you have the key now it's okay do you
think you can go do you really think you
can go what she well she about that
actually I'm I hope at least it says
tagged separate goodbye it's just a
chickpea I don't wait hey wait alright
finally yeah I'm excited to see what's
going on here
ah so this is the Zeppelin huh how's
that I still don't know what a Zeppelin
is oh cool sorry about having coke plays
Brock what is this what is this what is
happy no planks it's not talking I know
that for sure
something is wrong alright I keep
getting stuff okay there again the
mekinese oh no mechanism is against me
and the barrels why is it belt stop
hiding stuff from me barrels why can't
you just give it
okay so I guess we're looking for yep
yes I could maybe apostle the mechanism
is above the mechanism
mechana bears win the Scots it's
beautiful
I liked it can I go out I can't accept
this
so I have to break it that any of them
to Mecca and MS they don't wanna stop
makin a mess
move all boxes to see if there's clean
[ __ ] hidden from me add stuff from Ibaka
you had except for me that hat no
actually I just let you that's me ah
only reason why you're still alive
it's cus ah alright I'll jump here did I
miss something I don't understand
I don't almost um but this this is
making those sons wait what
bars else I don't understand the puzzles
oh no it's no
no way wait what is this what is it I
don't trust this what is this I stand on
it did nothing uh I think it's time
mushy right there's two of these maybe I
can use the barrels back okay let's put
one barrel here but the barrel but the
barrel good barrel and stay what no
don't need ammo
freaky barrels I don't know okay and
then we put another barrel here cuz
you're a barrel that's that okay did
that do anything I'm a genius
hahaha you didn't think of that I know I
will escape I will eject this lever so
hard Wow no it's out of order
I have a strange rod okay I'm trying to
do to make it a shame I'm trying to work
that out for you but it didn't take my
work I'm typing
I'll try next time write that Harwich
guys pretty mean I mean it's not Harwich
buddies I don't know what oh it's this
puzzle again
he's not order what is dance what is
this
what try to spin it they do it do it
right I might get the five the shocking
of all emerged is the open left side
right side mains up what what there's a
timer left side right side main lever
I guess wishes some main lever what's
the main library decided my painters
Tigers white what I heard the tag I read
the tag oh that's the fourth and what
after pushing the four time
now push it one time I pushed two times
three times push far times I did
something I did something that spinner
ooh this spinner ooh
spinner out spinner of spinner oh yeah
yeah and then you main done I did
something and I did I dad it's tag what
that what they don't want my stones I
don't understand mrs. schap tell me
oh-oh-oh snippety-snip aah what are you
doing hanging down wait wait
[Music]
try to avoid nice too bro thank you
damn that scared me good buddy oh oh wow
why would you do that hey me mr. charity
don't I just sit confidently just sit
back and relax I figured out okay just
track don't try to struggle but your
body's too big for me I'm stuck I can't
ever go what the [ __ ] did I do
I don't understand I don't own the song
I don't the song the song I didn't I did
something alright I mean I these doesn't
work anymore I don't own this that's
getting annoying I don't talk about that
meaning it's not funny no one's trying
to be funny you're not funny
hey so bad just kidding you are
depressed you Trevor Wow
what okay so I can't go out there Farley
maybe it's too cold or something I don't
give up I don't
the only one laughing at that all right
now what is deaf no can't spend X pinyin
and spending you did nothing
[Music]
it's almost seems as though what are
there maybe I can go this is amazing
oh now I get what does everything is
it's like one of those ah Wow awesome
map design cool stuff I like that I like
that a lot
I like a chippy can I get more than here
okay
and we didn't spend this right it's that
I get it we're we're flying and [ __ ] oh
man I'm slow and don't don't look others
two of those [ __ ] Wow geez Wow
where can I walk I don't get it try to
avoid try to avoid okay and you plan
don't like how am I supposed to avoid
them it's ridiculous
they're just pairing out of nowhere so
how do I avoid this little [ __ ]
okay walk here oh I get it I get it
come walk here thanks I can bail you
will do it fun of me and that I'm stuck
no no come on don't be stuck please
please please for me god damn it looks
like maybe the bureaucracy
well just one time yeah that's battle
save me alright I'm gonna do she's over
my head ah there's a reminder penumbra
overture were you supposed to walk on
those things in a certain order
I don't know I was really horrible that
Burnham report to be quite honest right
maybe it's where they are directed no
it's not I don't get it
quite frankly I don't get it at all okay
let's see drift at them this we can do
it okay we walk here first slow slow
jump okay that's gonna work either try
to avoid but how it's impossible it's
impossible why am I talking lights I
don't I don't know okay can we walk
underneath here Wow
don't hurt me promise
don't hurt Hey
so far so good hey not bad enough all
right let's just get up here
finish what we started I don't even know
what we started we did something all
right Jesus Christ I'm gently boxes
boxes cooperate please I'm trying to do
some [ __ ] here
why wasn't box with never cooperate okay
here we go
I did it I saw that you did nothing
okay what did I do there was a door
right that way what I don't even know a
thing was I even supposed to be here
I started it oh yeah sorry them settle
in and then we're done here I think at
least I don't know I start all right I
guess I'm fine
Oh Oh we'll see it's got to be
interesting because I don't really know
I mean of course I know I always have a
plan what do you think I okay wait what
do we do with this summoning circle oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah hidden
passage to to somebody's that came to
open from the room with the ten pillars
hidden passage to the summoning circle
the Hidden penis from Pasadena potable
peter-patter Paul Peter Peter battles
Jesus Christ how do I get out of here
why is it salt what what what's going on
I wish I could see he had me what is
going on by going I can't see [ __ ] oh
here we are I knew that okay
Jennifer
do you want from me the temper killers
payments 10 pillars peanuts where's the
10 pillars penis
it's gotta be here right oh yeah yeah
yeah I know
of course of course I know I'm a genius
you press the I mean of course you know
you know that to obviously has to be
here right now this is 10 pillars right
there's supposed to be like a shaman
charcoal here like that 1 2 3 4 or I
count many pillows and count many many
but it's this sanity potion I found it
ah all right I cheated a little bit I
actually got a message from the creator
of the custom story and he helped me out
he's getting a lot of people like huh
how do I do it is it's really difficult
cuz I'm sorry about anyway I'm supposed
to put it here I think nope well I'm
glad I got help from the one who made of
this cousin sorry sis now I can finally
[ __ ] Hey he said behind a big barrel
and I'm like there's I don't know got
savvy
I fell right there's a big vowel here
you're a big battle aren't you boy yeah
my dream god damn it it's probably
stupid all right finally oh man I've
been like searching this room like it's
so dark and then they said it's in the
corner of the room behind Alice and
there
there it is this is impossible just
jesus's penis okay finally I think it
just came
and then here's an chance yes yeah all
right we're in the summoning room or
whatever let's go to summoning circle
and I'm gonna end in here is your name I
should name there like favorite if you
enjoyed holy [ __ ] that's annoying I had
what to kill something now I'm gonna get
something to really keep that with the
killer anyway I like figures you do I
now see tomorrow
[Music]
you